foreign
[Music]
there's been something needling
at me for a couple months now because I
actually did check uh when this made the
news rounds and it was November so this
has been in my head for longer than I
even realized
Stephen Frye Stephen Fry is a fairly
beloved
British
actor commentator something of an icon
in a lot of ways
and he made the news back in November
specifically for noting publicly
something that I think a lot of us
already knew which was that he intends
to maintain his friendship with author
JK Rowling despite not agreeing with her
on things
um I cannot remember if he specifically
said that he disagreed with her on trans
issues but he basically made it a point
of I'm not going to cut off my
friendship because other people disagree
with her
part of why this stuck in my head
is because honestly
I can be sympathetic to that
I can be sympathetic
to the idea of a relationship that you
built
with someone
and they mean a lot to you and your
direct interactions with them are as
good as they've ever been in terms of
how you relate to them how they relate
to you
but something about them has come out
that makes you uncomfortable
but it's also something that doesn't
directly impact you
I mean I think the go-to example of this
would be
you know the
relative at the family dinner who
don't get them started on race
or on religion or on politics in general
or what have you
I think most of us can relate to that
and situations like that can hurt
especially if that family member say is
someone who we have a particularly close
attachment to someone who means a lot to
us
and it's very
easy
to basically just make the rule at
family dinner just don't bring that
stuff up and everything will be nice and
fine and we can have this nice
interaction and relationship
but my sympathy in understanding from
that perspective
can only go so far
hey there folks it's Vera from the
editing phase of this thing I am going
to be drifting off of Stephen Fry in
specific pretty soon in the video but
before I do I wanted to make note I kind
of feel like I almost gave him too much
credit because taking a closer
examination of his actual statements he
doesn't even really strongly imply that
he disagrees with or is made
uncomfortable by JK Rowling sentiments
towards trans people what he says is
that it upsets his trans friends so it's
not even a matter of my friend is saying
things that make me uncomfortable it's
even one step more removed from that
it's my friends are fighting with each
other and I don't like that and again
while I can have some sympathy for the
discomfort of that situation not taking
the time to examine why your friends are
fighting with each other just shows how
he is viewing this exclusively through
the lens of how it impacts him
because the thing is unlike
most of us uh and our
uncomfortable
uh uncle or Aunt or what have you
um
JK Rowling
and Stephen Fry
are public figures
with known positions
you deciding to continue to associate
with a relative that is yeah maybe a
little racist maybe a little sexist
maybe a little something
that
that may or may not be a great thing but
the number of people that that kind of
impacts the number of people might even
be aware of that is it's limited I'm not
going to say it's necessarily harmless
kind of depends on the specifics but the
harm is going to be fairly contained
because
how many people are even gonna know
that's not the case here and again that
can seem unfair seems like there's a
different set of rules a different
measure of judgment for public figures
but
there kind of is
not necessarily that something they do
um is not allowable uh but it is
allowable for uh people who are not
public figures or that something they do
is inherently wrong and where it's fine
for other people yeah and then I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about the
severity and the impact
of what they do is absolutely out of
proportion
so as I said
it may not be a great thing that you
continue to associate with that family
member
and that might make people who are in
the group that that family member is
railing against
think a little less of you
and they may or may not be right in
doing so again I think depends a lot on
the specifics
it is the same fundamental problem for a
public figure like Stephen Fry
towards JK Rowling
but the scale and the scope is grander
not just because there's more eyes but
the potential for damage it's a lot
greater as to what that damage could be
well I will get to that
I do feel that it's worth noting that
I'm not trying to single out Stephen Fry
because I'm trying to cancel him or
anything
he's just the idea that stuck in my head
I mean there have been a number of
people especially involved in Harry
Potter which Stephen Fry never appeared
in the films he did do some audiobook
readings I believe but there have been a
number of members of the cast generally
skewing on the older side so folks like
Ray fines Helena Bonham Carter the late
Robbie Coltrane who
most of them did not defend Rowling's
actual position but they did take her
side in the idea that she was being
attacked or bullied or canceled so while
most of them at least again from my
memory did not actually defend her
position in any detail and to the extent
that they did it seemed to be from a
position of not actually understanding
what it was she was saying and the
Damage it was doing that was kind of the
feeling when I saw what Ray fine said I
remember reading and thinking this just
reads like someone who is just taking
the word of his friend that people are
bullying her and has not actually looked
into what she said in the actual impact
of it which doesn't make it okay for him
to just kind of talk bollocks but like
it made me I guess less resentful than I
might have been otherwise
but again overall it's mostly your
defense of her like don't be so mean to
her don't be so rude to her why can't we
be polite
it's just a difference of opinion
many people uh with larger platforms and
smarter than me have pointed out that
um believing that a group of people is a
fundamental threat
to you uh is not a difference of opinion
because there's no middle ground
when the position of gender critical
people is that
trans people existing at all
around CIS people particularly CIS women
is an inherent threat
that's not just an opinion that's a
political position because you are
attempting
to control the movement and livelihoods
of other people
so no matter of opinion it is not
or at least it's not merely that and
never has been
but as I said
Stephen Fry's far from the
first one to sort of
talk about her but it was interesting to
me because it stuck in my head because
he defended kind of his right to have
that friendship
I also feel like before I go too far
down this road it is noting that not
every person involved in Harry Potter
has sided with JK Rowling
uh Daniel Radcliffe Emma Watson have
spoken out against her transphobic views
and also Harry melling who played Dudley
dursley and gotten some backlash for it
with a lot of people saying how they are
ungrateful because their careers exist
because of her which is first of all
debatable there is no way to prove that
they would not have gotten other acting
jobs and gotten uh any kind of
comparable career they're both talented
people
but beyond that that's just an argument
that's really gross to me
because by that mentality someone should
at all times respect and give deference
to
their parents no matter how abusive that
parent is
even the most abusive parents in the
world you should still respect and honor
and not speak against
and I would say that that is absurd
except I've learned the hard way there
are people who do in fact believe that
or at least espouse it
so that's it's not exactly fun
interestingly though it is a little bit
easier for people like Daniel Radcliffe
to talk about these things because
they're not involved with the movies
anymore
I mean I'm sure Warner Brothers
discovered would love them to be they'd
love to get them back to like do the
empty child or some it wasn't the empty
child no the cursed child empty Charles
Doctor Who an empty child is good cursed
child that's Harry Potter and it's
quite bad I'm sure on stage it looked
amazing but like as a story it's it's
quite quite bad
um but
they don't need this work they made
their money they both have steady
careers
they can say what they want
but somewhat more interesting was what
happened to one of the stars of the
Fantastic Beasts films Catherine
Waterston played Tina Goldstein
and she was the primary romantic
interest for the lead character of Newt
scamander she was arguably the co-lead
of the first two films
and then she spoke out very directly
against JK Rowling's transphobic views
and then somehow in the third one the
previous romantic lead and virtual
co-lead of the franchise was relegated
to little more than a cameo isn't that
interesting I tangented a little bit on
that issue but my point being that I
don't want to give the impression that
like all people involved in Harry Potter
have defended her some have some haven't
and Stephen Fry's relationship with her
seems to be not as tied into that
franchise as much again I know he's done
some stuff related to it but again he
defends
his right to maintain that friendship
and as I said I I do
get it
but seeing that he is known
publicly
as an advocate for queer causes for the
lgbtqia plus community and I just want
to salute and send my love and support
to all my trans friends and all
Transformers and people watching
to see him voluntarily stand alongside
JK Rowling that actually is inherently
damaging
in
a number of ways
one of those is that his position as an
advocate for the queer community
creates an image
that could be interpreted as oh look
there's someone who is a trans Ally
and who's still standing right beside
her
oh
I can still claim to be an ally or even
believe that I am
and still consume
her works
and Harry Potter related things
this is obviously coming up a lot right
now with the impending release of
Hogwarts Legacy which I don't want to
dwell on all that much
I honestly even without everything going
on I wouldn't really have a lot of
interest in it it's not my kind of game
there there are if the uh the overall
narrative is what uh the current public
understanding of it uh is painting it as
there's plenty that's actually going to
be uh dang problematic completely
separate
from um the way in which it bolsters the
voice of and financially benefits JK
Rowling
but
one of the things that's been very
frustrating for me especially with the
impending release of that game
is seeing comments from people
that basically amount to
I'm a trans Ally
but
I still intend to buy this game followed
by whatever rationale they give whether
it's because well she's already rich a
little bit more money won't matter I did
a whole other video where one of the
major points I landed on in the back end
of that was talking about how she has
said very clearly she considers every
single penny of residuals she gets to be
a validation and affirmation that people
agree with her so even if you think
putting your money towards Harry Potter
doesn't mean you agree with her she
certainly thinks it does
so but there's people who rationalize it
that way there's people who try and
justify what we have to help the
developers and the Production Studio
developers aren't going to get residuals
they already got paid and if the
development studio is on any kind of
solid footing they should all be already
be working on a new project and if they
get canceled then that was probably
already gonna happen if the studio which
I do believe is owned by Warner Brothers
is uh shut down it will not be because
this game did or didn't sell well it
will be because they probably had a plan
to eventually make them redundant anyway
it's actually incredibly typical in the
video game sphere but again regardless
uh the actual devs the coders the
testers they aren't going to see any
bonuses additional funds and there's no
guarantee that their workplace would
remain in business whether this is a hit
or not it could be a massive hit they
could still get shut down and have the
maintenance and updating hand it off to
a cheaper third-party studio now that
all the big um
infrastructure and the heavy leg work
was done
so I don't accept
uh that point either but then there are
some people who are
more honest which is they just say I
just really want to play it
I just really want to
engage in that world
I've dreamed of a game like what this
purports to be
and I do get that
but
while I can respect the honesty of it
you're saying that the material deficit
to the impact on the lives of trans
people
matters less than your enjoyment of a
product
there's also of course the people who
just openly flaunt their hatred of trans
people but that's not really who I feel
like dealing with today but yeah
there's a lot of that too and this is
the point where it's worth bringing up
no ethical consumption under capitalism
I am certain that there is someone
somewhere who
suffered or had is living in under
circumstances that are not ideal and
worse than they should be
that contribute and that situation was
compounded in order to enable the
creation and building of
nearly everything I enjoy pretty sure
everything on this Shelf
in some way reflects that
and
yeah that's true
and hypocrisy is
unfortunately a fact of life
but here's the thing
I can acknowledge that fact
and also acknowledge that it's not okay
acknowledge the fact that yes I do still
participate
in the society in the culture that does
these things and is built this way
but what I won't do
is I won't claim
to be an ally
of sweatshop workers
while buying cheap clothes
now does that mean my conscience is
clear no no it doesn't but there's
something about
the level of insult to injury
to hear someone say I support trans
people I'm against her transphobia but
I'm still gonna buy this game
or to hear Stephen Fry say I support
trans people
I support
your rights
but I'm still going to stand
next to the public face of transphobia
in the UK a country in which real policy
is being made
to make the lives of trans people worse
you can't do that and claim to care
about us
you can't
and I'm not saying Stephen Fry or
Ray fines or Helena Bonham Carter are
obligated to cut ties or end a
friendship
with JK Rowling they're their own people
do what feels right
but don't tell me that you're my Ally
while standing directly next to somebody
who has actively supported and had lunch
with
people and groups
who say I should be dead
there was a
tick tock
a couple months back from a Creator who
actually I think I'd even still been
following at that point she did a lot of
Harry Potter content but she
had in her bio that she was that she
stood with the Trans community
and apparently she had gotten invited to
the premiere of the they're a Fantastic
Beasts film and attended and did a
lengthy Tick Tock saying how great it
was basically serving as part of the
marketing and promotion for that film
and I went off
because the audacity
to claim to be an ally while actively
promoting that film I was very angry
and I wasn't even angry at the promotion
I was angry that she claimed to be an
ally
but that word meant so little
because if you're going to make any
claim or present yourself in a way that
even implies that you stand with us
that means you have to take
a stand
and taking a stand means losing
something
whether it be a piece of entertainment
you might have otherwise enjoyed
whether it be a friendship that you
cherish and has meant something to you
but that's what it means to take a stand
and you're not required
to do that
if you're not prepared to make those
sacrifices
that's your decision to make
but don't claim
to stand with us
or beside us or support us
or want better things for us
while refusing to stand next to us
and instead standing alongside the
people
who are trying to strip our rights
and this is by no means restricted to
trans issues
what I just said applies to basically
every marginalized group
people of color
the disabled
fat people
so many groups
get
trodden on
all the time and honestly
despite being trans and going through a
lot of crap
for being so
I've still got a lot of privilege I'm
white for a start
I know
that I still
probably have a lot of blind spots
and I try to the best of my ability to
be
as much of an ally as I can
two people of color to the disabled to
the neurodivergent
to
so many people to fat people yeah they
are genuinely genuinely
um
just stamped on
it's one of the one of the few groups I
would I would say right now where it's
socially acceptable to openly hate them
but
I also while I will say that I try and
I'm not even sure I can say I do my best
I probably could do better
I don't feel comfortable
assigning the role of Ally to myself
in my mind Ally is really something that
should be
bestowed upon you by the people
that you are an ally too
because if you either outright claim to
be or simply behave in a position of
being perceived as an ally to a group
but you are ignoring that group that
that group is saying
hey
Stephen try
you standing alongside JK Rowling and
saying that it's possible to maintain a
friendship with her creates an opening
through which other people will use
other means to rationalize maintaining
connections with people who are doing
damage or to continue to support her in
some way because they can go well
Stephen Frye is still friends with her
if it's good enough for him it's good
enough for me
how tangible is that damage I don't know
I can't quantify that blow for blow
but the damage she is doing
is immeasurable is that Stephen Frye's
fault strictly speaking no
no it's not it would be a absurd for me
to claim that it is
but he's continuing to stand by her as
she does it
and I know
I know
how valuable friendships can be
how much it can hurt
to have such a strong connection such a
meaningful bond with someone
but for this thing
and I know how tempting it can be
to hand wave that away
when it's something that you have the
privilege
of not discussing
us at our family dinners
we have the privilege of simply not
bringing up
the topic that will set off that one
relative
Stephen Fry has the privilege of just
not discussing trans rights around JK
Rowling and then the rest of their
relationship can be wonderful
we don't have the privilege
we are trans
and
we can't just ignore that and honestly
a lot of us would like to
I don't hear it as much now but I
remember a few years ago
that it would become a thing like oh
after you people come out all you do is
talk about being trans it's like you
make it your entire personality well
a lot of us have to keep talking about
it because
you won't let us forget
even if we wanted to simply just live
and exist like
I don't want to talk about this
I don't
I I honestly truly don't want to talk
about these people this subject I don't
but the world will never stop treating
me a certain way because of the fact
that I'm trans it will not let me forget
the fact that I'm trans
and so whenever I hear the accusation of
like oh Trans people are so obsessed
with JK Rowling we're really not
I would love nothing better
than to never talk about or think about
her ever again for the rest of my life
but it's like
you're trying to just walk down the
street and somebody is right next to you
shouting at you and you turn and go hey
could you stop please and then everyone
else around you go hey why are you so
obsessed with this person why don't you
leave them alone like but they're
shouting in my face no no you're clearly
obsessed with them
foreign
Stephen Fry is the privilege to not have
to think about
transness because that's not his
experience I have the privilege that I
don't have to think about race
I tried to not take excessive advantage
of that
again I'm sure there's more I can be
doing but
it's a privilege I have
there's plenty of privilege to go around
we don't get
to not think about
the harm being done to us
the restrictions of our rights as States
like Oklahoma proposed legislation that
would make it a crime to give gender
affirmation medical care of any kind to
anyone under the age of 20
26. this
is not even surprising
because the thing is
when gender critical people
wedge their foot in the door initially
trying to do it with bathrooms and then
later with gender affirming care for
young people
they were getting their foot in the door
by claiming we're just worried about
people who are miners
making decisions that they're not ready
to make well now they're coming for
adults legal adults
old enough to drive vote own property
drink join the Army die for their
country not old enough to take estrogen
or testosterone
if it is for gender affirming care
any
Advocate civil rights advocate
or queer advocate
could tell you and most of them have
been that this was coming
it was never going to stop at just the
bathrooms
it was never going to stop at just well
we won't let miners transition
there's always more
appeasement doesn't work
they weren't going to stop there
the goal
of people like JK Rowling and definitely
the stated goal of many of the people
that she has associated with and the
groups that she has shouted out
is to criminalize and in some way
eliminate
transness
they want us gone that's always been the
goal but they had to start smaller now
their foot's in the door and they're
wedging it further in
this was always going to be the case
and understand I'm generally cautious of
making slippery slope arguments but if
you think that if this can get passed in
Oklahoma that they're going to stop at
26 you're just not thinking through at
all why would they stop there
why when they can keep going
and I'm very cautious of slippery slope
arguments because I'm actually very
quick to say a slippery slope argument
is a coward's argument
because in a situation where we're
debating the merits of this
you're saying okay but if we allow that
but then this this this this this and
then that happens and we all agree that
that's bad right and suddenly you using
a slippery soap argument you create a
debate about this thing this
hypothetical thing that isn't even going
on
as a way to derail progress on the
original thing no absolutely positively
guarantee that the next movement is not
going to be allowing people to marry
their pet horse dog or cat and you know
what given the anything goes culture we
live in I don't think they can deliver
that guarantee so that's why it's a
coward's argument but there is a
situation in which a slippery slope
works and it's where there's precedent
and there is precedent
for the initial restrictions of the
rights of a group of people not stopping
at just one thing and going further as
far as they can push it there are tons
of instances with many different groups
there's a lot of precedent for what's
going on
and as all this is happening
people will say I have nothing against
trans people while they pre-order
Hogwarts Legacy or Stephen Fry
will say that he has no ill will to
trans people
while continuing to stand next to the
face of transphobia
in a country where it is becoming
institutionalized
you may have noticed that I'm not
shouting
in this video
I'm not even angry I'm tired
I'm exhausted
I'm exhausted by
people not only people claim to be
allies but actual trans people
who are still going to get this game
and I can't even bring myself to
have that much anger to them
they want something to
give them some joy in their lives and I
can understand that
I mean I still talk about Doctor Who
despite the
issues with the BBC News arm I would
point out it's slightly different in
that I talk about Doctor Who which is
made by the drama Department the news
arm is generally the bigger issue and I
also have the note at the start of all
my Doctor Who stuff I'd love to take it
down I'm not gonna
but again
you know
no ethical consumption under capitalism
it's all too interconnected
but I see trans people
say they're still going to get it and
some of them you can tell they're
agonizing over that fact While others
are just choosing to wash it aside with
some of the rationale as I said before
well I'm not thinking of it as helping
her I'm thinking it's helping the
developers it's just a drop in the
bucket she has all this money anyway
whatever it may be
it's exhausting
it's tiring
and it doesn't go away
I'm dealing with it more now because as
I said Hogwarts Legacy is coming out and
as a result tons of videos that I've
done in the past that even vaguely tie
into either that game or JK Rowling are
getting
um bombarded with fresh hate comments
every day
I have to block
dozens
of accounts
when I see hate comments
on my videos
and in replies to other commenters
I would love to not have to do it
anymore
but I'm also not going to stop
and understand most uh Youtubers of my
size will either Outsource somebody to
handle their moderation or they'll just
give up on the comment section
I don't really have the ability to
Outsource that and I will continue to do
it myself because I've known for too
long that there are people
some of my audience that part of why
they're here or feel safe commenting is
they feel that my comment sections are
nicer
than others they're not perfect and I
don't catch everything I try
but I'm not going to concede that ground
I'm done
conceding
anything
I will not concede the idea
that you can in any way shape or form
support someone like JK Rowling
or the
vast majority of the members of the GOP
or the GOP as a whole
and claim to be an ally to trans people
I will not concede that not even in
principle
I will concede no ground
because appeasement doesn't work
and you're not looking to find a middle
ground where we can all live happily
you want me gone
and I won't go
because as I have been hearing
as a chant since the 90s when this
phrase meant nothing to me personally
because I didn't think it would apply to
me
but it does
I'm here
I'm queer
and I'm not
going anywhere
and if you find that inconvenient
if that makes you feel bad if my
presence
feels like
I'm trying to guilt you because you want
to buy this game
or if it makes you think about things
you rather not think about or if you
think I'm ugly
tough [__]
I'm not
going
anywhere
whether
it is fair weather and fake allies or
outright hatred
you will not deter me you will not stuff
me back into the closet
because we do have actual allies people
who actually stand with us and we have
each other
if you want to buy that game you buy
that game
just don't claim to be an ally
and if the idea that you can't claim
that anymore makes you uncomfortable
maybe examine that
or admit
at least to yourself
that maybe even if you don't actively
hate us
you don't care about us enough to
inconvenience yourself
start with honesty
at least with yourself
if no one else
Stephen Frye
just admit to yourself
that our well-being
matters less to you
than your friendship
that is your choice
you have a right to make it
and
you can continue to raise all the money
you like
for queer causes actually I hope you
will continue to do so
but it won't offset what she's doing
bolstering her voice
and lending validity
giving people an out at all to think
they can continue to support her
without doing damage or that maybe it's
just not that bad
the world is messy
and it sucks
it sucks
and I'm not without sympathy
but I also won't budge
stubborn
stubborn bastard that I am
as these things
happen
and as they weigh on me
and on the times that I can't get them
out of my head
I'll be back
and you can choose to be here
or not
but I'll still be here
thank you for listening
if you want to support my ability to
continue to be here I have a patreon and
there's other things besides there's
links down in the description for all of
that
but the thing I need you to remember
as we move forward as best we can
and I do mean this to anyone
who is still watching
even if you disagree with me
even if you're going to buy that game
even if you're Stephen Frye
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
though if you are going to buy that game
or if you are Stephen Fry you're not an
ally
but regardless if you are still watching
you are the council
and I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
well it's patreon supporter Shout Out
Time folks so thank you to Robin Moore
Zubin lupula to rock the thing that goes
doing in the anime Oliver B Angus
bjornison Linda Walters IMU delki Theo
the Boyd toy lowly Becky Sparkle for
Nabi lacks the poodle Zach Tracy scrabot
General contact unit Problem Child angry
gaspro Tim price Adam RDL Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose thanks so
much for your help you can get your name
right out too check out the rewards in
the patreon
what they should do should they check
[Music]